some stuff we could all learn from they
say listen to him
and um make him the head
to keep it simple no no no what'd you
say last time
well empties
[Laughter]
Philly's belly and empty is sick every
day
what are you is yeah this feel their
babies and empty their sex all men will
be happy
[Laughter]
she got into more detail last night
oh yeah no I just think
I don't know I just think that the
traditional women they always had sex
all the time hence all the children and
the happy men you know the distance to
stay at home they just worked really
hard and
sometimes modern women just don't like
to give their husbands lots and lots and
lots and lots and I don't like sex how
long have you really how long has your
relationship 32 years and we're still
having sex regular oh yeah
it doesn't say they're tired
just tired for what two times four so
I'm never tired I'm never tired I drove
135 miles just to have sex with him
that's how good it is because he wanted
to and he said to me you're up for it
and I said yep I'm in the car and there
I was how many modern women to do that
you said they went out of finish you
went to work and then I went back home
what do you what do you say to women
um that say they can't do it every day
just don't put on your makeup and you'll
find time
because they always find time to put on
makeup but they ain't gonna five times
for like how long does it take to put on
makeup how long does it take to have sex
what five minutes what about when
they're crying what about when what
about when they're pregnant
that's the best sex that is the best sex
when you're pregnant I think it depends
on how your pregnancy is going yes if
you really I mean
obviously yeah obviously if you're sick
that's an exception I'm not going to say
that the man's gonna say hey you're sick
let's have sex and you're gonna say no
it's gonna say because I'm talking about
every day in general what about the
jewelry what about a headache what about
a headache right
the biggest light gets a bit of a
headache it does no as in the biggest
lie that women say is oh they have a
headache I have a headache well then
they should know that sex gets rid of a
headache what's it what's your sex
really pain so you would upset that you
see there's a lady and she confirms it
honestly I have a question I'm not
saying it's me but how about for the
women that don't enjoy it or like this
but then don't have a man
or allow your man to go find a woman if
you want to be a housewife about sex
allow him to step out and have sex
because you can't just get you can't tie
down a man and then once you put the
ring on your finger and say sorry I
don't like it no more we're gonna turn
around and says you're sorry I don't
like you no more that's a lot of rubbish
every woman having sex with you leave
her
uh wave six isn't like the main thing in
a relationship what what kind of
relationship is that it's not the main
thing but it's extremely important you
need to be connected honestly right
after your children it's sex with your
man okay yeah you need sex to be healthy
what if the guy doesn't want to have sex
with the girl oh my god well then he's
getting he's dead he can't be alive he's
got to be dead he's got he's got to be
dead he can't be alive he's got to be a
corpse I feel like women have a higher
sex drive anyway naturally so why they
keep on pretend like they don't and
don't free it up more often I don't know
that's not me though my issues I mean
because I'm an unsatisfying the women
that's why they that's why they come up
oh please
how can you say that a man is not
satisfying you when people open their
legs and you won't say to the men it's
good many tips sometimes help them out
does it say helper yeah
if you're having bad sex it's the
woman's fault because she knows her body
the man knows it's just all hanging out
he can bang against somebody can get an
odd on do you know what I mean but the
women know what they like so as far as
I'm not baggy but you know what I mean
but the women they know what they want
is more internal you know I mean there's
more bits and pieces to fiddle around
if it's bad sex it's a woman's fault I
wouldn't be like that guys don't like
certain things so as a guy you tell them
it's simple to make again that brother
no yeah obviously but I've got Free
Fighter with the Twister the best thing
is for
get the grip in there
explain each other what you like and
what makes you happy and then sex will
be great there's nothing stopping it the
only person stopping it is you and by
not saying anything that's right the
only person that can stop you from
having fun is you so Auntie is this your
is this your first relationship
[Music]
s yes okay so what happened with your
previous relationships like why did they
break up or end
yeah she said with the bus driver but
this one yeah but if they cheat if
they're abusive but this one's a lifer
so do you feel like women are to blame
it for man cheats no I don't think
they'll be meant to blame it for man
cheeks I thought women have to blame
they keep on staying with the man and
then complaining that he cheats every
man cheats you don't like it get rid of
him if you stay with him he continues
cheating shop about it so if um would a
man cheat because you were offering him
good sex but yes a man would cheat if he
wants to cheat
I've just found one yeah
there's literally nothing you can do to
stop him no but I've found one that
doesn't they're the Rarity but they're
out there
so if you were like just say the
traditional good woman why did the man
cheat or what happened that's the
traditional room is going I've got
nothing to do with his dick it does what
he likes with it as a traditional woman
how can I say
the men will tell you it doesn't matter
it's not hard to take it personal it's
not about oh they're in love with this
woman that's what it's just like as I
heard the young man say they've got a
nut to bust and they did that's it but
why would he not bust it with you like
maybe you went there at the time you
could have been at work and she was hot
and cold she was hot and available right
that's what I'm saying like like Eddie
was saying earlier sex is different for
guys than it is for girls we not all
girls some girls can just have sex but
some most girls have an emotional level
to it whereas guys can just bust a nut
to anybody
it doesn't matter
because [ __ ] happens like if he's gonna
cheat he's going to cheat there's
nothing you can do to stop and often the
guy's an achiever God don't even look as
good as these main girls are that's how
you know that's how you know a brother's
a dog when these girls is like cool if
the girl's nicer then you can kind of
validate that cool it makes sense but
more time it's just she was there rat
plays right time right circumstances and
[ __ ] went live I'm not advocating for it
I became foreign
men need discipline the boys ever look
back and think oh you know what my
girl's actually really pretty why did I
cheat with this other of course as soon
as they must have not they think that's
really
straight
away
it doesn't get harder over that girl and
then take you on holiday that's how you
know it's on my team you stop buying you
bear [ __ ]
that's how much he loves you that's how
much he loves you because as soon as he
bust that night he's like you know what
I miss my babes
it's the worst day when you realize you
have to worry about ugly girls too
women don't like eight percent of men
men don't have that standard they just
they like they're like 50 they swear on
50 of the time yeah they would probably
just swiping but if they're in front of
if the woman's in front of them that
goes up to 80 90. you're saying what did
you say earlier you said if the if the
guy turns the girl down for sex he
should be dead is there he did she'll
kill him yeah no I mean I wouldn't
they've got to be so wrong with the girl
because I can't see no man turning down
a woman that's why I said he must be
like a corpse
nah I don't disagree with that It's
gotta be something that's
maybe it's a fishy smell I don't know
maybe already
no no no no no no no this is where I
have to come in because at cool I
believe fundamentally that men need to
learn sexual discipline yeah to to not
be a dog in doggy situation so for me
personally I took a year out of six to
learn sexual discipline just so I could
have the power to say no when the time
was right so there was times when I'm
I've got a girl in bed and we she said
look I'm gonna come over we're going to
watch a movie
before I probably would have tried to
make a move now we're genuinely just
going to watch a movie because I've
learned sexual discipline I think that's
important but not every guy
I got invited onto a date and they said
where do you want to go and I said I
want to go to the movies and because I
don't like people in front of me so I
just chose the backs the background me
not thinking now we're older people back
row I was like we're talking about what
are you doing because I'll buy for us at
least right I won't come to watch the
movie
it's about the movie I said I've got a
house there if I want to go back to but
no all this Netflix and chill no no
that's what I'm saying it's a sexual
discipline for a man is important to
mitigate those situations for both for
both was that with your partner no
because it was a friend it was just a
date supposed to be a date okay on
fashion dates like back years ago
old-fashioned 32 years ago you're trying
to check me
don't [ __ ] up I'm 54 years old no I'm
not gonna change me my son's 36 what
else do you want to know no I'm saying
was this date before you met your this
partner
yes okay so this was and what if I said
to you that it was a date when I had my
partner I'm just asking okay then no I'm
just asking does it make a difference no
no it should though shouldn't it think
about it you should it should no I'm
just asking no but you're asking for a
stupid reason because it should no I'm
asking because
you said um old people because obviously
I'm trying to say because you said
something about old people but my son's
36 so I've got to say that in it no no
but I just thought that you went like
obviously if you went in your even early
20s you're not old you get what I mean
yeah it's only because you said oh as
old people you know you didn't know what
the back was so I thought 20 is not old
do you get what I mean that's what I was
asking you yeah like would it make a
difference she's still not getting what
I'm saying because it should make a
difference it should make a difference
why are you asking the question
basically the answer for you shouldn't
be here
like us old people something now what
I'm saying is that you're missing the
point